v look at the history and literary life
of dover delaware on c-span two and
three
next on the civil war a look at the
secret society known as the knights of
the golden circle that sought to
establish a slave empire spanning the
southern united states mexico cuba and
the west indies created in 1854 by
george bickley a virginia-born doctor
the organization later shifted its focus
to overthrowing the u.s government and
carrying out clandestine operations to
support the southern cause in this
program author david keene talks about
the key members in the secret society
and their role in pushing for succession
the national archives hosted this
hour-long event
thank you doug and thanks to everyone
for uh coming out
today i want to give you uh
an introduction to the knights of the
golden circle and also give you a sense
of how my book
came about
the
washington
is certainly a
suitable place
to make this presentation because the
knights had their headquarters here
it was formed in
[Music]
september of 1859 and by the end of 1861
they led a plot to take over uh the
government part of washington dc and
take it out for the south in addition
many of the records of the knights are
held upstairs in the national archives
and folks from the national archives
over the years have been very helpful to
me
in finding them so i can rev could
review them for the book
now
as doug mentioned
i'm basically
have been a regulatory attorney in fact
i started my legal career across the
street at the federal trade commission
at the 7th and pennsylvania avenue and
had a 40-year
legal career from which i retired from
full-time practice in 2005 with the idea
that i wanted to write a book
my wife's a noted author of historical
fiction for young people we wrote a
travel book together and i wanted to try
to write a book of my own i'm a history
major from gettysburg college i like to
investigate things and i was hoping to
write a historically oriented book where
i might make some new historical
discoveries
i started out writing working on
researching a book about lincoln in
kentucky in early 1861
and i don't know whether you know it but
at the time
kentucky was up for grabs it had
declared its net neutrality and both the
union as well as the confederacy were
doing their best to try to get to
kentucky to come to their side kentucky
had tremendous manpower resources
industrial resources as well as
agricultural
production and lincoln reportedly said
i'd like to have god in my side but i
must have kentucky
sally's gracious relatives live in
georgetown kentucky and we went down
there for a number of weeks to do
researching research and while going
through the micro films of early 1861
at the university of kentucky in
lexington
i discovered repeated references to a
secret society called the knights of the
golden circle
now the the the uh newspaper reports
were
made by this man this is uh george
prentiss george prentiss was the editor
of the louisville journal uh out of uh
louisville and he uh
actually his paper was so prestigious
that it was read throughout the country
one of the few papers that lincoln had
delivered to the white house every day
but prentiss said that the
knights
were the central arm of the secession
party in kentucky he said they had six
castles in louisville they held a may
convention in 1861 at which 8 000
knights attended and prentiss asks why
the titular head of the knights george
bickley who was the president of the
american legion uh was not arrested and
tried for treason and this is george
bickley
bickley
replied to prentice on may 30th in a
letter that he sent to the pro-south
louisville courier which was actually
another paper down the street from the
louisville journal
and bickley said that the lincoln
administration had instituted a legal
crusade against the knights
that with regard to its secrecy he had
published copies of its secret degree
works and given him to kentucky's
governor all except the oral portion of
the secret third degree
and he confirmed that there were eight
thousand nights in kentucky and said the
work will be pushed with the utmost
vigor until the tri-colored flag of the
confederate states
floats in triumph over the dome of the
capitol in frankfurt and that's the
capital in frankfurt
bickley claimed he had sent 535 men to
the confederate army from kentucky
already and that further regiments were
now forming
prentice then followed up by august with
his own expose on the knights and he had
somehow gotten copies of the
uh super secret third degree
and uh you noted that the knights
initial intent had been to establish a
slave empire equal to the grandeur of
ancient rome in the golden circle and i
think you can see the golden circle was
the southern united states mexico
the northern central america and the
caribbean islands
they hope to put key members of their
third degree in key positions there and
establish a monarchical type government
and reinstitute slavery
now the knights spoke in code and they
used passwords and they use signs of
recognition so one night would know
another this for example is the code of
the knights that was used during the
civil war
a.a urban was actually a third degree
member of the night who had given a lot
of their secret documents to
george prentiss
the knights were structured in three
degrees
at the bottom were the
general membership
and
the members of the knights army it was
called the order of the iron hand at the
height i estimate it's about 50 000
members across the united states
the army ranged from 7 500 to probably
10 000 at its peak
the second degree was the order of the
true faith this is where the enablers
these were the money men who raised
money for knights projects as well as
the
editors and for example in texas there
were 20 different editors who were
affiliated with the knights and
published favorable publicity
connected to them then there's a third
degree the order of the colombian star
and this is a super secret degree that i
mentioned these were supposedly top
political and military leaders in the
country their identity was kept secret
so this was the governing degree they
could formulate the plans and orders of
the knights and pass them down to the
lower two degrees and particularly the
knights army and no one would even know
where they came from but the lower
degrees were obligated by oath to obey
them
i thought wow when i saw this
this may be the type of thing that i'm
looking for and i came back to i'm from
allentown pennsylvania
wrote several
chapters in a book about lincoln and
kentucky but i included this material on
the knights and i gave it to our
neighbor who happened to be the chairman
of the history department at muhlenberg
college
my neighbor read it and we met at a
local restaurant to talk about it and
his advice was he said dave a lot of
people have written about lincoln and
what you have is very interesting but i
have never seen this material in the
knights of the golden circle before and
so i suggest that you concentrate on on
that and i did and i've been thankful
ever since
i then went to the internet to find out
uh what might be in the internet by the
nights and there's all kinds of myths
and legends about him you know john
wilkes booth was a night leader and as
i'll get to he actually was
they were behind the lincoln
assassination uh they had very gold the
southern gold they had buried it across
the south so that the south could rise
again
and they're still actually
if you want to take a vacation you go
out in arkansas and they have
groups that go out looking for the gold
of the knights
they also were tied in with jesse james
and his gang who contributed to the
knights gold one of the most
popular renderings was this national
treasure 2
disney movie that came out in 2008 with
nicholas cage
he
it begins with a castle which was their
lodges of the knights of the golden
circle before the lincoln assassination
ripen the night before and then the
lincoln assassination takes place and
then nicholas cage and his cohorts go
off looking for the gold of the knights
of the golden circle
in addition to monitoring renderings at
the time of the civil war there were a
number of these authentic expositions
published by
anonymous members of the knights and
they sold some of them hundreds of
thousands of copies and made similar
spectacular allegations like the one
says that the key members of the
buchanan administration which was the
administration right before lincoln took
office in march of 1861 were members and
leaders in the knights and they
specifically mentioned
john breckenridge from kentucky who was
buchanan's vice president and actually
ran against lincoln for the presidency
hal cobb a secretary of treasure from
georgia and john floyd who was
buchanan's uh secretary of war
well i asked myself how much of this
could be true and i set out to try to
find out
i looked in in general historical texts
and uh you know
often they they have a civil war they
might have a few paragraphs on the
knights maybe even a page but then they
sort of trailed off into uncertainty and
speculation
there was a 2003 book by a new york
times reporter and an arkansas treasure
hunter called shadow of the sentinel
that contained some history on the
knights a professor at marquette in the
1950s named frank clement did a lot of
work on the knights but he was really
looking
during the civil war
in the midwest which is i'll get to as a
period when they were
actually dying out
probably the key journal article is a
1941
article that appeared in the american
historical review by an historian called
allenger crenshaw
called
the career of george bickley
i utilized five different search engines
you know today you can go on to the
internet and they have these
uh some engines have 50 100 newspapers
that you can search remotely and put in
knights of the golden circle
1858 to 1865 and push a button and
articles come out they did that for five
different ones and really got hundreds
of contemporaneous articles on the
knights i found some hard to
find masters theses particularly in
texas where they were much more
transparent about the knights activities
one by a woman is a professor in texas
now who went across texas to archives
into
newspapers and libraries and found
evidence sort of she created dossiers
maybe on 50 or 60 different nights
as well as the 30 different knights
castles in texas the knights were very
powerful in texas they had been
instrumental in affecting texas's
february of 1861 secession from the
union uh an informal army of the knights
led by ben mcculloch had forced the u.s
army or out of the 22
u.s forts along the texas frontier and
so they were very powerful in texas i
asked if they were this powerful in
texas
what about the rest of the country
i found that the knights had been formed
by a merger of a cincinnati medical
professor
with a pre-existing
southern group called the order of the
lone star and the medical professor i've
already shown you his picture this is
the young george bickley who was the
fellow who founded the ritual for the
knights now bickley sort of is a story
unto himself he
uh had grown up in south west virginia
he uh
his father died when he was young his
gallivanting mother
with out with men in richmond and
petersburg and she sort of sent george
to live with relatives south of
petersburg he grew up a loner at 12 he
ran away from home he traveled around
the south visiting relatives started a
training business in southwest
alabama trading with new orleans he
ended up with relatives in indiana at
one point and then he came back to
southwest virginia and he studied
medicine under a medical doctor
which was the way many people learned
medicine those days and worked under a
doctor for a year and then opened up his
own practice in the taswell county hotel
now georgia's specialty was phrenology
uh you may know
was at the time a popular uh sort of
like a an old-time form of brain surgery
but they they would measure the bumps on
your head and uh they felt that by
looking at the bumps in your head they
could tell your personality your health
your future all kinds of other things
and that was what george was studying
george then somehow
bluffed his way into an upstart medical
school in cincinnati called the eclectic
medical institute
he lied and said he went to uh
school in philadelphia as well as uh
london he would by the way during the
period he was roaming around the south
he became a very convincing liar
and he then went
to the eclectic medical institute worked
there a few years and then found out
there was a better way
and he married a rich widow in
cincinnati
named
part of the kinney
family of wealthy bankers
and she and him went to her farm she had
a farm about 100 miles east of
cincinnati where george engaged in all
kinds of speculations with her money he
was selling farm implements to russia
coal mines in the dominican republic he
started a a magazine called bickley's
west american review
that
was dedicated to the concept of manifest
destiny and at the time manifest destiny
was the idea very popular uh in all
parts of the country that the the us and
particularly the white race was going to
sweep across the american continent it
was its destiny destined by god and then
the add-on to that was they were going
to go south into uh the southern
hemisphere uh george also started a
drill team a lot of military men these
would do ex
exhibitions military with
marching and rifles and it was very
popular at the time that the drill teams
would
compete against each other and it was a
way for military-minded men to get
together
he was doing all right until his his
wife discovered that in addition to just
using her money he was actually trying
to abscond with it and put it under his
own name and she got his brother to kick
him out so george had to go back in hand
to the eclectic medical institute
he taught there a year he worked for a
patent magazine this was like in 1857
and this is where he got the idea for
his knights
and and you may know at the time the
novels of sir walter scott like not
ivanhoe were just very popular and were
sweeping the country and particularly
the south so the motif of the knights
was just uh
very popular the the chivalry uh in some
of the southern resorts like at the
greenbrier they would have jousting
contests where five or six thousand
people would come from washington uh and
and different places and they would
have knights jousting and lords and
ladies in the stands and this was very
popular particularly in in the virginia
resorts
um
in 1858 george headed south
to
the south to get more money and to raise
money for his knights particularly with
the wealthy plantation owners
uh
somehow he was able to link up when he
was there with a pre-existing society
called the order of the lone star that
had been formed in 1851
by two u.s senators
senator henderson from
mississippi and
pierre soulet
from louisiana and the purpose of the
order of lone star was to try to take
over cuba there was a thing at the time
known as filibustering where not the
legislative type but where a general
usually well-known general in the u.s
would go out to the port cities where
there are a lot of
military-minded and idle young men and
would raise a private army
like new orleans and san francisco and
even some cases baltimore and new york
and then they would cut a deal with one
of the two warring factions in south
america or central america and then
would go off to try to take either the
country over or land and treasure one of
the most famous filibusters was a
gentleman named william walker and
walker in 1857 uh he was walker was a
tennessee medical doctor who became an
editor in new orleans and he went to san
francisco and in 1857 he led a ban of
immortals of about a hundred to
nicaragua that were allied with the lyon
faction in nicaragua and they took over
nicaragua and made walker president and
they reinstituted slavery and he lasted
for several years until he crossed
cornelius vanderbilt in his shipping
interest and vanderbilt funded the
surrounding countries to kick walker out
well the order of the lone star was
interested in similar filibuster in cuba
and
they in 1854
convinced a mexican war hero named john
quitman
to
raise a private army and quitman went
out to do it he supposedly reportedly
raised 50 000 men in a million dollars
and six ships were being fitted out they
were getting ready to go into cuba
when uh
and the president president franklin
pierce had given him tacit approval of a
wink and a nod and all of a sudden
pierce changed his position on the cuban
filibuster now the thinking is one of
the reasons he did it was congress
passed a thing called the
kansas-nebraska act which allowed
slavery
north of the old missouri compromise
lines and people in the north became
outraged by this in fact lincoln was so
outbreak or outraged this is with the
thing that brought abraham lincoln into
politics
so
all of a sudden pierce shifted position
uh quitman said he couldn't go without
at least tacit approval so he gave up
the filibuster and
the order of the lone star sort of lost
its mission and this was the period when
the order of the lone star joined up
with the knights
well bickley next headed out to the
washington baltimore area to try to form
the his knights on a more formal basis
one thing this is the american cavalier
it's a newspaper that bitly published in
baltimore a military journal devoted to
the extension of american civilization
in it when you read the number of the
issues they're now shifting off of cuba
and looking much more at northern mexico
this is saint vincent's church it's near
the dock area in baltimore uh there was
a castle of the knights at saint
vincent's church this is near the
neighborhood where john wilkes booth's
family had a a winner home
booth joined the knights in
august or the summer of 1859 but he did
it in richmond he was part of the
dramatic star company and he joined with
several other members of that company
but it's likely when he came back to
baltimore in the winter he tied in with
the castle that was near saint vince's
church one of the members there was
michael laughlin one of the
the lincoln conspirators his brother
william mclaughlin there was samuel
street another number of identified
parties were members of that castle
in addition to them
probably
either that castle or another castle
this gentleman was connected cipriano
farandini who was a sicilian
hairdresser or barber at barnum's hotel
in baltimore and
besides being a barber farrandini also
was a drill master for various militias
he had been a militia leader in
baltimore he had actually gone to drill
the mexican army at the point where the
knights were looking to take it over and
his biggest claim to fame is he led the
cabal that was going to assassinate
lincoln in february 1861 when lincoln
came to washington to assume the
presidency
uh this is the night's commission for
farrandini it's held by a private
collector but it basically notes that
ferendini joined the knights as a
captain in august of
1859 which is the the point when they
were having their convention at the
greenbrier resort in southwest virginia
another notable
knights leader in baltimore is this
leader he headed the maryland regiment
of the knights
charles robert charles tyler
he was a former walker lieutenant who
had fought with the band of immortals in
nicaragua he then came back to baltimore
served as a clerk but spent most of his
time and his money building up the
knights in in the maryland area
others involved were william byrne who
was a breckenridge elector and headed a
group called the national volunteers
john v l mcmahon was a fiery attorney in
baltimore who represented baltimore's
rising merchants now there is also a
castle of the knights in washington
congressional testimony indicates that
it was at temperance hall around four
and a half street although the
temperance hall we've discovered is
around 8th street so we're still trying
to to sort that out but bigly boasted
that knights drilled with an earshot of
the white house in 1861 that there were
regiments in maryland and virginia
the political head of the knights in
washington was uh l2 washington
lucas quinnis washington who was an
editor
uh a political operative and was tied in
with virginia secessionists uh
you know many of his friends were from
virginia he it also
the uh
the military head was probably a
guy named colonel boyle who was
a
medical doctor but and the war went off
and became a colonel uh cornelius boyle
in the southern army
in any event i mentioned that in 1859
the knights had held a convention at the
greenbrier hotel in which 80 to 100 uh
political leaders and military leaders
from across the country attended
and out of that convention they came to
washington and established the uh their
principles of the kgc their rules and
regulations uh with their headquarters
at washington dc it's it's under the
name of the knights of the columbian
star which was a super secret third
degree it's a success slick 60-page
booklet that describes the night's
constitution their maxims orders uh how
to form a castle uh goes through all the
documents of the knights and connected
to it was a secret degree works which
had the rituals of the three degrees of
the knights
those documents by the way are upstairs
in the bickley's files
bickley was captured by the union
government in mid-1863 and the trunk
that contained all these documents was
taken and it is housed here at the
national archives
now the overall goal of the nights
was
you know to
expand uh in the golden circle area
expansion and slavery and also they were
the militant arm of the southern rights
clubs which had been formed across the
south
but
by early 1861 they began focus focusing
on northern mexico and that's the area
where you read in the paper about the
drug wars were occurring well at that
time it was a barren area but it had a
lot of minerals and so the knights were
interested in land and treasure and you
know they they cut a deal with some of
the provincial leaders in that area
the
the guy who uh pushed this was this
gentleman akana greer greer was the
regimental was the brigadier general in
charge of the knights for texas and
arkansas he had regiments of 3 500 men
of the knights army under his wing and
he wrote to the knights of the old order
the lone star area era which was like
mississippi alabama louisiana and texas
saying i have
two regiments of knights and half a
million dollars we're ready to go into
northern mexico won't you join me and so
bickley rushed down
to try to figure out what to do
because greer and these other guys were
going to go ahead into northern mexico
now at the time mexico was engaged in a
horrendous civil war
where uh general miramon controlled the
central part of mexico
he was a part of the conservative or
clerical party and a mexican uh folk
hero benito juarez who was a part of
indian from uh southern mexico
uh controlled he was the head of the
constitution or the liberal party and
they controlled all the coastal areas
and they fought for years and neither
could gain the ascendancy uh and the
knights tried to cut a deal with both
sides they were to give their army to
one side or the other uh they did make
some headway with some of the the
provincial leaders under juarez but
never with juarez himself
but in any event uh in
in
in early
1860
thousands of knights started forming on
the texas mexican border like around
march they came not only from texas and
from the south but they came from new
york from richmond from virginia from
the midwest uh you know reporters were
saying knights are coming here
from all over the place and they were
getting ready for this uh
filibuster into mexico when all of a
sudden and bickley was supposed to
arrive with another million and a half
dollars and a division of men and he
shows up empty-handed
well this caused all kinds of problems
the knights leaders had to go back out
to mississippi alabama and georgia to
try to raise money but the knights in
new orleans and there was like a
thousand nights ready to go they were
they revolted and jefferson davis
brother-in-law joseph who was a
filibuster leader uh basically called
bickley a fraud and an imposter
bickley and rushed to new orleans to try
to you know put out the problem uh it
didn't work so he had to leave and
he left to go to montgomery alabama to
form the knights uh you know to call a
new convention of the knights he
melodramatically resigned his position
as head of the knights army and his head
of his political arm and they had a
convention in may uh in raleigh north
carolina
one of this is one of the key
discoveries that we made we're going
through old newspapers in norfolk north
carolina which is one of the hotbeds of
the knights and we discovered that
the order that bickley sent it went to
virginia's groener the head of the
knights in virginia and
north carolina
for this convention but attached to it
was a document i don't think was
supposed to get in the paper it was a
secret circular letter that spelled out
the knights uh the the number uh in the
knights army on each state and who were
the knights leaders in each in each of
the southern and border states
and the knights were concentrated at the
time in three areas texas and arkansas
where i mentioned at 3 500
georgia mississippi alabama where they
had another 3 000
and
north carolina
washington and virginia where they had
another three thousand and one of the
reasons they had another three thousand
was because of uh
this gentleman virginia scroner
groener was the head of the knights in
virginia north carolina
he had a military-trained background he
headed a militia unit in out of norfolk
he went to texas he served under
the with the texas rangers he was a
friend of sam houston the rangers were
filled with knights he came back to
north carolina and worked as also a
lawyer in richmond and formed the
knights
throughout virginia and north carolina
the
the knights
held their their convention and at the
convention they accepted bickley's uh
removal from the uh army but they kept
them in charge of the political arm
because he had all these contacts in
washington
but
he
they they really became decentralized
and they uh you know they became
decentralized under the state regimental
commanders this was another one to give
you these were top political leaders
this is a guy named paul j sems
sems was a brigadier in the knights he
was a the head of the
columbus guards out of columbus georgia
that were so respected that they led
jefferson davis davis's inauguration
parade he raised troops for
the southern army and went off as the
head the brigadier general in charge of
the second regiment of the georgia
infantry
the knights were tied together because
they were under the state leaders at
this time
by roving emissaries groener was one
this was another one this was ben
mcculloch who was a noted uh texas
ranger and also
u.s marshal out of texas he was also an
arms dealer and he would travel around
the country selling coal and other arms
which gave him a perfect opportunity to
tie in with
the night leaders as well as the
southern governors and reports were that
all except for three of the southern
governors
were members of the knights which makes
sense it doesn't hurt if you're running
for political office to have a secret
large secret society behind you
after the convention the knights decided
uh rather than continuing to push with
their mexican it was where the state
leaders of the knights decided rather
than trying to push with their mexican
intervention they were going to now
switch their support to the southern
governors many of whom were pushing for
succession and at this point the knights
became
the strong arm of succession they
you know intimidated unionists
in many of the southern places they held
pro-secession rallies
there was
some of their editors talked about fires
which did occur in texas but this spread
across
the south creating fear across the south
of
fires which they said were led by um
abolitionists who were uh instigating
the slaves
and so there was a lot of
fear and uncertainty created by the
knights
they were also described as the nucleus
for a southern army to rally around in
the event of secession
and
for example the charleston mercury was
published by
one of the southern char the fire eaters
born well wrecked in october 31 1861
said the texans are almost to a man for
a fight if the abolitionist lincoln
should be elected they regard bickley's
forces as the most available nucleus for
an army and millions of men did join
front organizations called the minutemen
in many southern states and the national
volunteers in washington baltimore and
new york
the the knights hall the castle of war
at marshall texas in november of
1861 uh three of the things this was
this was infiltrated by a u.s army
informer and was reported on up through
the army command and actually the
secretary of
uh lincoln's secretary of the treasury
chase where it appears in his diary but
they
had
decided to capture the u.s forts in the
south and i mentioned the 22 forts along
the texas frontier but there's also
indications of knights activity in north
carolina and mississippi even before
those states had seceded they they said
they're going to seize the district of
columbia which i'll get to in a second
and we're going to prevent abraham
lincoln from taking office and i
mentioned the effort in february of 1861
by ferendini and others to try to
assassinate lincoln as he passed through
baltimore
now
as the war was getting closer uh greer
and from texas tendered the knights
regiments from texas to his
brother-in-law who was south carolina
governor frances pickens groener went
from went from the council of war to
mississippi where he tendered knights
regiments to the governor of mississippi
john pettis
uh
there there was an attempt to uh seize
washington in uh
late 1860 they um
there were various
reports on this by the governor of
maryland hicks by supreme court justice
john campbell uh by a texas congressman
called emile evans
uh
there was newspaper reports that ben
mcculloch and 500 texas rangers were
over in northern virginia getting ready
to
attack washington and actually stanton
mentioned that mcculloch was casing out
different of the fortifications in the
district
one of the most uh
graphic ones was by joseph metal who was
the managing editor of the chicago
tribune and he wrote lincoln in december
of 1860 he says the evidence of he was
in washington the evidence of my eyes
and ears are forcing me to believe that
the secessionists are seriously
contemplating resistance to your
inauguration in this capital there is
certainly a secret organization in this
city numbering several hundred members
having that purpose in view sworn armed
men in branches and lodges affiliated
with them in design they extend south to
richmond raleigh and charleston
he indicated that
they would first need to control
baltimore but if things go to us for the
next 60 days as they have for the last
30 baltimore will be under the complete
control of the disunion elements he then
warns if the intention of this it is the
intention of the disunionists if they
get baltimore on their side to prevent
you reaching this city washington by
force and with the aid of the lodges
here and in virginia in the south to
clean out the republicans here take
possession of the capital and proclaim
the southern confederacy
now there was actually a congressional a
select congressional committee of
congressmen of five members of congress
that were designated in december of 1860
to look at these rumors of the knights
of the golden circle and their attempt
to seize the capital and
assassinate lincoln and one of the
members happened to be a
pro-south gentleman from north carolina
who left
slightly thereafter and joined the
confederate army and he was a dissenter
but the the other ones heard 20 20
witnesses some of whom were actually
involved in the conspiracy they heard
ferendini the the
fellow i mentioned from baltimore the
hairdresser
and they also heard another guy named
hilliard uh and like ferrantini came and
he basically said i'm not gonna you know
kill anyone and the reason i'm uh
training militia in baltimore is to
prevent northern troops from going
through and hilliard basically
later admitted that he and ferendini and
other knights had agreed just to lie to
the committee and not say what happened
but despite all that the committee
concluded
that
after two weeks of testimony
disaffected persons at least informally
consulted on resistance in the counting
of the ballots to the inauguration of
lincoln the seizure of the capital and
the district of columbia
uh this has been read
rendered contingent upon the secession
of maryland virginia or both
uh and then it's sort of set in
washington goblin group there is no
proof that they intend to attack the
capital or the district unless the
surrender should be demanded by a state
to which they possess a higher
allegiance or read another way if
virginia or maryland secedes then they
might attack the capital
one of the fellows who was leading the
southern effort in washington at the
time was this gentleman louis wiggfall
he was a u.s senator from texas from
marshall texas where he was tied in with
the knights he was also initially from
south carolina where it was tied in with
the secessionist elements and he led you
the the pro-south uh members of the
congress both the senate and the house
and holding meetings which were
pro-secessionists many of them resigned
but wigfall remained in the u.s congress
until february of 1861 to spy on what
was going to happen and to try to
prevent the union from
formulating effective efforts he went
during this period he went to baltimore
and actually recruited troops for south
carolina in baltimore and sent several
companies of national volunteers to
south carolina to help
help in its defenses which were
eventually resulted in the firing on
ford something a counterpart to wig fall
was a gentleman in northern maryland he
was from hartford county where booth was
initially from called robert harris
archer and archer this is his colonel
certificate he joined the knights in in
late march 1861 but he recruited troops
uh in like cecil county hartford county
uh to go to the south and to uh to go to
south carolina and help man the defenses
his brother by the way was john james
archer who was a brigadier general in
the confederate army now at the time the
knights had about fifty thousand members
spread across the country uh they were
in california they were in oregon where
they were going to take over san
francisco forts and establish a separate
pacific republic
and i decided to pull together what i
had at that point
and write a magazine article and this is
an article that
appeared in north and south magazine in
june of 18 2008 called strong arm of
secession the knights of the golden
circle in the crisis of 1861.
the knights were instrumental in texas
they were they were important in
virginia they tried to help push
kentucky and maryland and other states
out of the union
the article
came to the attention of dr michael
parish who is the head of the history
department at baylor university and dr
parrish contacted me
dr parrish heads an imprint at louisiana
state university press which was my
publisher called the conflicting world's
imprint and he basically confirmed what
my friend from muhlenberg college said
he said dave the knights of the golden
circle is one area where it real about
the civil war history that really hasn't
been covered and we really need a book
in this area and if you would take your
article and write a book
we would like to publish it
so i knew i had a publisher and i
continued working
you know the knights were some of the
things we won't be able to get into
today uh the knights helped orchestrate
the pratt street riots uh in april of
1861 there was uh
a mob that attacked union troops of
going through baltimore
and
members of the knights including john vl
mcmahon had met the night before to try
to
to instigate the riot
actually the where i'm from in lehi and
brooks county the troops from our area
went through the day before in march
18th and were the first in the country
to reach the capitol they were housed in
the congress and they still have
meetings today of the first defenders of
pennsylvania as the troops that were
able to make it through
to the defender capital at that time
the knights contributed men
and
leaders to the confederate army the
confederate army at the time in february
of 1861 the confederacy roof was formed
it didn't have an army it went from
nothing to 200 000 men by september and
of 1861 and one of the reasons is whole
castles of the knights of the golden
circle in places like texas and arkansas
joined the confederate army in mass
many of the state regimental commanders
that i mentioned were
brigadier generals in the confederate
army greer groener
groener was a colonel but sems and some
of the others for example in texas of
the 30 castles
the captains of those castles 75 percent
joined the confederate army and there
were captains are higher
well the our area where i mentioned the
first defenders uh we also had castles
of the knights in berks and lehigh
county and our local paper did a feature
article on my book coming out but they
wanted a local connection so i knew they
had a castle and we went out and we
found in the history of lehigh county a
report of where the castle was located
it was north one mile north of linville
in lehigh county so we went out to try
to find it and my wife's a photographer
and this is a picture we took this was
the meeting place of that castle it was
it was the meeting place until the
unionists discovered and threatened to
blow the house up
and then they wisely moved the castle
meeting somewhere else but there was
another there's other reports of the
nights in foglesville in in berks county
where i was born and raised there were
nights at mooton and also at stouchburg
which is uh near wilmelsdorf uh west of
reading and during this during
april of 1863
three knights who were from that
stoutsburg castle were arrested in
reading and were taken to
philadelphia where they were tried for
conspiracy
so the knights were
active in pennsylvania and other parts
of the country
well in may of 1816 the knights
continued their threats against lincoln
in may of 1861
joseph holt was the judge advocate
general under lincoln and he was from
kentucky a strong unionist uh but he got
a letter which is in the library of
congress from his aunt and it said
joseph uh your nephew john has just
joined this group called the knights of
the golden circle and she found out they
took an oath to remove lincoln in his
cabinet
there were there were oaths that have
been posted in
ohio
that said i will not rest or sleep
until abraham lincoln now president
shall be removed out of the presidential
chair the knights that were captured in
berks county in 1863 one of the things
that they said in newspaper articles is
that they were they were hoping to
participate in the abduction of lincoln
lincoln regarded such threats from these
they called them dark lantern societies
with good-natured contempt he sort of
took a fatalistic attitude about it he
said they're going to get me they're
going to get me there's probably not
much i can do about it there was a
pigeon hole in his desk that had 80
letters 80 threat letters on his life
many of them undoubtedly coming from
members of the knights of the golden
circle one of the reasons that lincoln
refused to compromise in april of 1861
at the beginning of the civil war they
were trying to work a compromise called
the crittenden compromise proposed by a
senator from kentucky but lincoln said
if we compromise and we allow slavery
anywhere south of the missouri
compromise lines it's only going to
encourage groups filibustering groups
like the knights of the golden circle to
try to take over uh mexico cubans and
central america
now by 1864 the knights were being
subsumed by other super secret societies
once called the sons of of liberty but
they did become a bogeyman for the
republicans and were used very
effectively in the election of 1864 that
helped elect lincoln for example
before robert e lee's troops came into
gettysburg scam artists came in adams
county and sold the farmers insignias of
the knights of the golden circle and
said put these in your window and then
when lee's army swoops through they
won't hurt your farm
and so they did that they bought these
and they put them in the windows and uh
jubal early one of these lieutenants in
his memoir said we came into adams
county and they were waving these things
and we had no idea what they were so but
the joseph holt wrote a report on the
knights uh he really reported on the
later secret societies but he used the
knights sort of as the front the uh the
front part
in october of 1864 his report on the
secret society
as i mentioned john wilkes booth was a
night leader he worked with the knights
in memphis and other places in his
smuggling operations he sold he smuggled
quinine he was probably i mean his
sister asia talked about a meeting with
men in philadelphia strange men coming
in the middle of the night in late 1864
they were probably nights they were
whispering at all times of the nights
there are a suspicious number of nights
that were involved in the lincolnis
abduction first they tried to abduct
lincoln and take him to richmond to
exchange him for confederate prisoners
and then that failed when richmond was
evacuated and changed over into an uh
booth in the assassination but there
were knights who appeared to be involved
in both plots
there was booth obviously
the
for example
the uh
uh
the lachlan brothers i mentioned they
were both nights they're documented
nights lincoln stagehand edmund spangler
uh who held the door at ford's theater
uh is reputed to be a knight the
customer the actor
who was there doing suspicious things in
the united assassination named lewis
carlin was one of the gentlemen the
actors who joined with booth in
the summer of
during the knights of the golden circle
robert harris archer the colonel that i
mentioned uh who had the knight
certificate from harford county he was
picked up in a row boat
in the potomac river at the point when
booth and harold were expected to cross
and uh the feeling was that he was uh
trying to assist them in their escape uh
the confederate sky met spy man
spymaster from washington cornelius
spoil uh he was at he was in charge of
the confederate camp under lee at orange
courthouse virginia which is where booth
said he was going
and they were going to go to mexico and
that's where boyle went shortly
thereafter and there's actually in the
lincoln assassination a number at least
one
suspicious letter from a secret society
member to boyle and the sarats
uh basically saying that they're going
to kill lincoln chase and others i mean
the assassination plots were much
broader than lincoln and seward they
were talking about a whole slew they
were trying to wipe out the top of the
union government they were trying to
kill grant and sherman and so uh groups
like the knights of the golden circle i
was very initially very skeptical now
i'm becoming a believer believing that
they were
involved washington papers the day after
the assassination
said that the knights of the golden
circle were behind it
lincoln's special judge advocate general
who was brought in henry burnett to
review the assassination evidence he
reports that i find the footprints of
the knights of the golden circle
crossing my path in all directions and
this is a wood print from the library of
congress it shows
came out in late later in 1965 it shows
that the theory of assassination was
bickley the practice was booth and the
effect was the martyred president
well i submitted my draft for review to
lsu press in 2009 thinking i was almost
done
but with academic presses you get a
second reader who are usually anonymous
but are noted historians in the area and
i had historians reviewing my manuscript
asking questions i had to revise parts
and finally i got a second reader who i
later found out was dr robert may from
purdue university who was a noted author
and expert on the filibusters and dr may
had some very
favorable things to say about my book
actually the first blurb on the back is
from dr may
but among other things he said that the
book was
written and i tried to do this that the
text was written for the general reader
it was a
chronologically structured fast-paced
and clearly written narrative and i
tried to put the endnotes in the back
the material that the scholars would be
most interested in but in any event he
concluded his comments to lsu press by
saying you must publish this book
and they then went by
gave me a contract in 2011
i then discovered how there was still
more work to do i wanted to have
photographs in the book so i
included a photo gallery but i had to go
largely across the south the archives
and universities acquiring photos of
some of the nice leaders that you've
seen today
how to come up with a cover and they
accepted my idea this is a cover it's an
antique map showing the castle of the
knights of the golden circle and their
flag their their barrel flag as they
were getting ready to go into mexico in
april of 1861 which incidentally is
housed in the bikley files at the
national archives upstairs
we had to review the page proofs we had
to create an index uh develop a
publicity campaign my daughter allison
helped me develop my website
davidwww.davidkeen.com
where
lots posted if you want to take a look
at it
but
it brings us to where we are today
it took me much longer than i imagined
when i started out seven years
each chapter became a story unto itself
because each chapter covers the knights
in a different area of the country but
it was a fascinating journey with a
number of notable historical discoveries
i have shown that the knights were more
powerful than the historians have
previously assumed and played a more
central role in the outbreak of the
civil war
bickley in his abbreviated biography
which he put out in 1862 which is not
really just a paragraph he says i have
built up practical succession and
inaugurated the greatest war in history
and to a certain extent
he's right
thank
you maybe do we have any questions i
think if you come to the microphone
please don't do what i can answer was
there a connection between the knights
and the emergence of the ku klux klan
after the war
the uh
the knights died out one of the places
when they died out was in pulaski
tennessee and it was also where the ku
klux klan sprang up
uh in april uh
in 1866 in nathan bedford forest but i
have not been able to establish that
let me say one thing i didn't mention
was the fact even with the lincoln
assassination uh when i'm talking about
people who were knights it doesn't mean
the others weren't knights i mean
remember the knights were sort of
obligated to keep their identities
secret
and so when i've discovered that someone
was a knight it was usually from a lot
of digging a lot of detective work so
there's probable other members of the
lincoln assassination in nathan bedford
forest and others might have been
knights i just haven't been able to
establish that is there maybe that's
your next book um
question
were the nights uh significant in
southern illinois i've heard that they
were
yeah well the knights uh during the
early part of the civil war
were significant in southern illinois
southern ohio and southern indiana
they had castles there
but
by 1863
the castles were sort of switching over
to and bickley
got captured
by union elements most of the knights in
the south as a matter of fact
went into the southern army so in the
south they weren't all that effective
anymore because they basically gave
their allegiance to the southern army uh
in the in the border states and in the
midwest lower midwest they were active
but in in around 1863 they started to
switch over to another order called the
order of the american knights which was
out of st louis and several of the
members who were members of both said
that was because the knights of the
golden circle were by that time so
infiltrated by
union detectives and spies that there
was no longer you know they could no
longer communicate without knowing who
was who had infiltrated them so there's
new secret societies that sprang up but
during the early part of the civil war
yes they were active in those states
you said that uh breckenridge was a
knight and i believe you said all the
three southern governors were knights
but jefferson davis was not a knight or
what about his cabinet and vice
president and did
the knights were they able to
intimidate some of the state
legislatures and uh into uh secession as
a and you know try to put down the
unionist
the uh
the the the expositions that i showed
you also said that jefferson davis was a
knight i don't know whether he was or
not but i mean these were by anonymous
members so you don't know who's saying
it but they also said that he was a
knight
breckenridge is some evidence of that i
mean there were reports that he wore
night medallions when he was vice
president in
washington
and
there's also reports that crittenden
when he got back to kentucky accused
breckenridge of being a knight so i i
attached more credence to that and your
second question was what about the
intimidation of the state legislatures
in the south uh by the knights and
especially the intimidation of the
unionists
they were very effective i mean they uh
uh you know there was threats of
violence they looked through luggage uh
when northerners came down and this was
particularly places like texas and
piccolo admitted it you know when
northerners come here we look through
their the luggage uh we drive them out
they blame
uh northernest abolitionist preachers
for uh you know brainwashing the minds
of the children in the south against
slavery and so they did their best to to
kick them out interestingly in kentucky
however uh you know i mentioned began by
noting that they had tried to do that in
kentucky
and it was largely bickley at the time
because a lot of the other southern
leaders were already in the confederate
army bickley did a lot of bombasts he
did he's going to take over the capitol
in
it would take over the capitol in
frankfurt the knights were going to
march across the ohio river and split
the
northern ohio in half
those bombasts actually turned against
him and in kentucky uh lincoln sent in
lincoln guns he had his friends like
joseph speed one of his best friends at
speed brothers from louisville and they
actually uh joined together
and uh were
when when push came to shove
and the southern army entered
under pillow entered from tennessee and
grant came from cairo the legislature in
kentucky backed
grant the unionists and one of the
reasons for that is because i think the
reaction to all bickley's bombast so it
actually hurt them by that time but
earlier they were you know the militancy
was much more effective
dave in my own research i've come across
a group in philadelphia called the
knights of the blue gauntlet where there
are splinter groups from the knights of
the golden circle
they're they're during the civil war
they they use different names and i
can't i do know one night leader i think
he showed up in connecticut and he was
calling himself the knights of the
golden squares by that point but he had
the same he had the same documents of
the night so they used different names i
can't say
about the gauntlet but actually in
philadelphia this was last week i spoke
to the philadelphia union league the
civil war roundtables at the civil war
union league which had been formed
because of the southern sympathizers in
philadelphia in 1862 and bruce's sister
lived there asia and booth would come
there and you know southern sympathizers
would get together and the unionists in
philadelphia felt they needed a place
where they could talk in confidence and
that's why they founded the union league
there so uh but that particular group i
can't say for sure
anything else david we're out of time oh
okay thank you for coming all right well
thanks so much
the civil war airs here every saturday
at six and 10 pm and sundays at 11 a.m
eastern time
to watch more of our civil war
programming anytime visit our website
cspan.org
history
and to see what we're up to during the
week or to send us your questions and
call